うん
前回按分でこっち側大日焼け止め
こっち側を開けする奴を塗ったんですけどもあまり効果がなかったので今回はトーディ
免除ということでこっちが半分のこっち側日8月をするやつでこちら判断はクローラー
ジックで塗ろうと思います黒は光を吸収しますなので体の半分のこっちがを黒マジック
でコンティ
そういうことがあって太陽の光が吸収されるつまり直接肌に当たることがなくなる
一切日焼けしないと僕は見たわけですよこれ最強では多分黒マジックで寝るのが一番日
あげたい先
日焼け止めはあんまり効果なかった今回はこっち反応黒マジックで全部打ってこっちが
反応が超日焼けするよ
ウイましょうジェンヌっていこうぴょん
先にマジックでこっちが半分のこちらを黒にしていきましょう
すー
[音楽]
せず今回検証なので体の前部分だけ黒くします
me
油性かーうるせーかー
[音楽]
とりあえずこっち側がこっち側の重音だけを全部黒にしました
sps 0真っ黒になりやっと塗っていきましょう
めっちゃ黒くなるぞよし準備完了前半
フィギュア期スタート思うよ
[音楽]
キッズ止め厚くしてめっす
すぎだ後6時間やりましょうばいばーいまあ
[音楽]
あっあーっ
じゃバイ
[音楽]
ん
はいだけでえっ
コーナンデ勘襲っ
スピア減の柄に使ったんですけどなんかもう熱水書みたいなつっ
と全開なので1回洗い落としてきて色の違いを見てみようと思いますでは
洗い落としています
[音楽]
ます
いっ
日焼けしてない